I'll start so my name is James Powell
and you're supposed to say hi James here
yeah we can do better than that I mean
we're on camera so we can make least
sound to the YouTube audience that
there's a lot of people in the room very
good we're at PI data Seattle it is
Sunday July 26 2015 if you'd like to
follow me on twitter you can follow me
at don't use this code if you'd like to
email me you can email me at james at
don't use his card calm and a long time
ago i had a blog that i'm in all the
presentations are given the last three
years I've promised to keep updating at
seriously though uses code calm now one
of the purposes of this slide is to let
you know that I'm full of bad ideas in
fact I don't think I have anything
that's not a bad idea I think Kyle Kelly
and Jake van der plants in the audience
can attest to that and in fact this talk
is probably a very bad idea before I get
into why this talk is a bad idea i just
wanted to mention an organization that
makes this event possible numb focus i'm
a volunteer with numb focus and i've
been helping this weekend to try and put
this event on numb focus is the 501c3
that funds projects like julia ipython
notebook it provides fundings like other
projects like numpy it is the
organization that makes a lot of these
tools that use an open source data
science possible it's the organization
that makes pie that a possible in fact
this year num focus will be hosting over
4pi thatís the for the four major ones
are dallas at SMU London Bloomberg
Seattle Microsoft and New York bank of
america coming up we've also hosted
smaller pie that events in florence in
paris and in berlin so numb focus is
what makes this event possible and you
should be sure to thank leah and the
other volunteers and um focus as many
times as you can today they are an
amazing crowd and it's an organization
that needs our support so in general
about me i speak about python i speak
about software engineering i speak about
quant finance every so often i speak
about that assign to speak about machine
learning and if you like this talk or
you want to get some more fire eNOS from
me i spoke earlier this year at pi
tennessee i gave a lightning talk of
high
montreal i gave a talk at our stats in
new york city i was the token non our
speaker i gave a talk at pi that at nine
in dallas has a thing we're doing now
we're numbering the pie thatís i spoke
at the open data science conference in
Boston I spoke up I'd out of 10 in
London I spoke at PI data 11 Seattle if
you'd like to find me I'll be at PI
Gotham in New York I'll probably be at
PI Texas i'll be speaking at strata in
new york i may be speaking at PyCon
canada in toronto and i'll probably be
speaking yet hi that on New York City
and I may also be speaking at ODST in
san francisco and actually forgot
there's one more at the end and i'm a
i'm a head out to Spain again to speak
it I can't spin so if you have already
gotten tired of me now that we're five
minutes into my talk don't worry you'll
have plenty of other times to avoid
coming to my talks okay so I wanted to
give you a little history of my
interaction with the PI data conference
series by the way we're now numbering
pie that I so he's that's the thing i'm
trying to get started so i gave my very
first pie that I talked at PI data
number one which is in new york city at
lighthouse international in 2012 and i
talked about generators and i thought
people love generators so i'll talk
about it again at PI data to at silicon
valley at which was at the end of pike
on in 2013 and i thought let's broaden
things a little bit because i really
like C Python as well and I like really
low level stuff so i gave a talk about
number i gave a talk about embedding so
python i gave a talk about generators at
Pied out of three at Microsoft nerd
Center in Boston and you know these
topics are very interesting so I talked
again about embedding so Python at
january's applied out of four at a New
York at JP Morgan I repeated those talks
in London at level 39 i reworked one of
those talks about generates because
people really seem to like generators
it's Silicon Valley of facebook and I
thought you know what we got to get some
generators up here in Europe so I gave
that talk in Berlin at the end of Europe
Python the Pied event that we held there
and then I started to focus i got a
little tired of generator so I wanted to
give a little talk about some C Python
internals and some black magic at PI
data eight the New York that's the one
where Apollo Creed comes back
hey and earlier this year I I actually I
actually started with a new talk this
talked you're going to hear integration
with the vernacular and I also gave an
impromptu talk C Python meanderings
which was me I would say I was in the
bathroom my phone rang and they were
like oh my goodness the speaker's
canceled can you come up on stage and
give a talk so that's what C Python
meanderings was and then in London I
gave this talk integration of the
vernacular so what is this talk all
about this talk is about the numpy
approach it's about trying to
conceptualize what we're doing when
we're using numpy or how numpy
integrates into software development
practice the purpose of this talk isn't
so much to convey an opinion about
whether it's good or bad but to try to
create a language around engineering
modeling about software development as a
field unto itself about software
engineering where it doesn't just mean
writing code because there is
engineering the software beyond just
writing code and i would say that one of
the most disappointing things about
software as a field is how de based it
is really when we talk about ourselves
to software engineers we are nothing
like actual engineers there is nothing
even approaching engineering analysis
there's no conceptualizations there's no
shared vocabulary or there's very
minimal shared vocabulary how often do
you see two professionals in another
field in a conversation and one of them
says to each other oh let's repeat to
ourselves what we learned in the 101
version of this class and yet it happens
in software all the time there's no
expectation of some shared knowledge
base or even some shared idea right no I
I haven't had an opportunity to bring
this up before Steve McConnell but this
is this is my own personal opinions
non-representative of any of the other
entities that I do happen to represent
the purpose of this talk is to try to
introduce some language for describing
exceptional izing software and software
development and it's not to talk about
numpy as being good or bad or this
approach about as being good or bad in
fact numpy is actually pretty darn good
there are a lot of corners there's a lot
of really rough corners to numpy and in
some cases you know there's some still
some long-standing bugs in it and some
areas where it hasn't really been
polished
but one thing that computer scientists I
feel don't do enough that engineers do
all the time is they look at an
imperfect world and they say well you
know this is good enough for getting
some work done we're doing some good
it's not perfect it's not elegant it's
kind of sloppy it doesn't work in all
cases but this is what we're working
with and in that case numpy is actually
pretty great I will warn you that this
talk is totally inscrutable but who
cares this is one thing that I've been
I've been thinking about a lot after
giving this talk twice this year which
is you know who really cares about this
stuff and certainly nobody here to us
especially not data scientists I told
you that I gave a talk at our stats in
New York City and the reason that I gave
that talk was that the person who was
running that conference Jared Lander is
somebody who I've invited to speak at pi
that events in the past as a token our
speaker in a Python conference and so he
said I'll return the favor and you could
be the token Python speaker in an our
conference when I got up on stage I
realized that I was speaking in front of
an audience that didn't care about
anything that I was talking about they
were data scientists who don't care
about software there were our
programmers who don't care about Python
and that's really the case data
scientists are usually people who are so
involved in a task that they're working
on that small things like engineering
considerations don't really matter to
them and North should day you have more
pressing concerns you have problems in
front of you that you really care about
that you really want to solve and in
many cases your work is idiosyncratic
you're working to produce some output
and it's only the output that matters
the process or the procedure that you go
through isn't really that important to
the people who are signing your paycheck
you're not building these large
engineering artifices or in many cases
you aren't or you're not doing that yet
in fact much of your work may just be in
an eye Python notebook and the only
thing that you're delivering to anybody
is the results in the last cell so a lot
of these considerations around software
engineering don't really matter although
I would say that they actually do really
really really matter it's just that for
the most part you can kind of scrape by
and pretend that they don't i would say
in fact that many of the people in the
audience are actually engineers i think
it's very interesting
when you look at the author's behind a
lot of projects an open source and if
you look at their BIOS you'll see that
there that they describe themselves as
physicists or astronomers or biologists
and yet much of what they're known for
is not physics or astronomy or biology
but contributions to open source and in
fact there is a case of a certain
gentleman who is in the physics
department at a very large University
and is leading a very large project and
as I understand that all the classes
that he teaches are actually in computer
science and this is an interesting case
many of many of us who are data
scientists or even scientists a lot of
our time is spent in software to the
point where we really are software
engineers you're just not trained it at
all and we don't care about it and
that's somewhat problematic as a result
I've been looking for this talk for a
long time not the specific talk because
I can't say that I'm looking I can say
that the talk that I'm looking for is
not the talk that i'm myself able to
give but i've been looking for more
people to talk about these kind of
things to talk about at a very high
level modeling and engineering and
engineering software engineering as a
process as I dynamic development process
and all the considerations around that I
view engineering is fundamentally a
human process so it's not about the
elegance of the math or the elegance of
the code or any of that nonsense it's
about how do we create these artifacts
these these physical things these lines
of code that serve some human need that
serve some human process that actually
achieved some goal I would say if we
wanted to belabor a mathematic analogy
we could say that what is it when we sit
down to code I always wonder i started i
started by thinking about what am I
really doing what I'm saying out of code
I'm not creating art I think that's
absolute nonsense because I'm being paid
to do this and that's not to say that
artists aren't paid but the purpose of
doing this is not to express some inner
beauty that I see in the world the
purpose of this is to achieve some
concrete goal the purpose of this is to
achieve some concrete goal that is very
well correlated to me getting paid so
that I can have a roof over my head and
what I think that we're doing is we're
serving some business need by automating
some
process and in the process of automating
that we need to take an infinitely
profound universe reduce it in
complexity is something that can be
expressed in a computer and the process
of that is essentially the creation of
an algebra that is we have some objects
and we have some properties and we have
some relations we have some operations
that can be performed on them and the
code is encoding those operations and
encoding certain characteristics of the
domain in the codomain and we're
establishing those characters who
establishing those properties of the
code that we write and when we're
running it and hoping that this
extrapolates to the entirety of the
domain right so if you were to define
some field or some ring or some
mathematical structure for me you would
say here's the operation here the
numbers that it operates on but you
wouldn't say well just to make sure this
works I'm in a test edition on 1 + 12 +
21 + 2 and just keep going on and on you
wouldn't have this iterative enumerative
approach this enumerative approach that
Dykstra criticized so heavily you'd say
I'm establishing these properties and
I'm saying that this is a sufficiently
well defined algebra such that those
properties extend to all of the inputs
that I'll get providing the outputs that
I can expect and that's what software
really is but let's not label aber
mathematic analogies instead let's
belabor social science analogies so the
title of this talk is based on some
research that I did my undergraduate on
socio political movements and language
in modern China and in the early 20th
century in China there was a May fourth
movement it was started on the fourth of
May in 1919 in Beijing it was in part a
student movement and also a movement of
intellectuals and very closely
associated with this movement were many
authors and these authors are considered
to be the eminent authors of pre
contemporary Chinese literature they are
the joseph conrad's or the bill cobbs of
Chinese literature their names Lucian
mountain and Lhasa and they are tip one
thing that typifies what their literary
style was the use of
vernacular Chinese this is something
that may seem a little bit odd to many
of the English speakers in the audience
but prior to the May fourth movement
much of actually all of written Chinese
was not written in the vernacular what
you would write in a book was not what
people actually spoke and it was not
even close to language of people
actually spoke it was a classical
language there's a language that had
existed for hundreds of years prior to
this point and one thing that typifies
one of the very provocative things that
these authors did was they wrote books
in the language that people actually
spoke one thing that typifies this older
style of writing this classical Chinese
is the existence of idiomatic
expressions and idiomatic expressions
exist through to even modern Chinese one
example of them is falling leaves
returned to their roots lawyer yet way
gun and if you were to figure out what
this phrase means if you look up in your
dictionary you wouldn't see a single
definition you may see a reference to
some classical texts and in this case
the classical text is the records of the
transmission of the lamp and you'd see
that this comes from some phrase some
dialogue between two characters in that
text and its meaning is not to be taken
sola scriptura its meaning is the result
of some classical interpretation and
hundreds of years of people interpreting
and studying this text in fact this
particular phrase that is very very
common in vernacular Chinese is
originates from this document that's
from the Song Dynasty which is many many
many years ago and you can kind of look
up the dialogue that it comes from and
if you look through this you may find
that the phrasing that you expect shows
up right here and this is something that
we're somewhat familiar with in English
we have some of these callbacks in
English we have them in the names of
titles Shakespeare is a very good
example we have many titles of many
works that call back to Shakespeare and
these callbacks are not always these
illusions are not always obvious to us
North by Northwest is one example what
dreams may come as one example murder
most foul is another Star Trek six the
undiscovered country is another
sample the Wrath of Khan unfortunately
is not from Shakespeare we also have a
lot of phrases that we borrow from it
from Shakespeare as well that people
don't even realize come from sex but it
didn't exist prior to to his
introduction foregone conclusion is from
Othello see changes from The Tempest to
send somebody packing is from Henry the
sixth but this is very different in
Chinese and that even in this example of
this one phrase you can see that while
this phrase has been adapted so if you
look at the first set this is the modern
phrasing of it and in modern Chinese
you'd say lawyer gueguen but the actual
historical phrasing of this is yellow
quakin and actually swap the first two
characters in order to make it a little
bit more palatable to a modern ear
however this is not just like something
this is not just some phrase that
existed in an old book this is a phrase
that integrates very poorly into the
modern vernacular Chinese because for
example if you had a sentence like this
proposal is not guaranteed to go through
which your translate into chinese is
this and note that chinese is an
isolating language it has no
inflectional morphology meaning we can
actually break it down into word by word
we'll see that on this line here
guaranteed is expressed by this for
character proverb nice long run where
the thing is if you speak Chinese and
you read this that phrase pops out to
you it's being used in some adverbial
sense but it's very obvious that it's
not well integrated into the language
into the vernacular language it just
exists as this concrete indivisible unit
and here's some reference for where it
comes from very very rarely just want to
actually look up the references for
where these phrases come from but you
can always look them up and see where
they come from in this particular case
it doesn't actually exist in the modern
form at all so this is something that I
know it's a belated analogy but this is
something that that really struck me the
more I got into programming with numpy
that is I always felt that numpy really
poorly integrates into the vernacular of
modern python that is everytime numpy
shows up in my code I can see that this
is numpy code I can see this is not
idiomatic Python code this is based on
some
incantations or based on some structures
that existed prior to the contemporary
Python vernacular and it's something
that just sticks out like a sore thumb
just in the same way that these four
character proverbs stick out as a tort
them to a native Chinese speaker when
they exist in the vernacular but let's
briefly go over what numpy is I don't
think the audience needs it that much
but it's a library for scientific
computing a numeric computing it's the
basis of tools of like scifi and pandas
and so I could learn we might look at
numpy and say that it's a collection of
algorithms things like matrix operations
but that's not really what it is and we
might say it's a collection of things
like f of T and constants and operations
like that but that's not really what it
is I think numpy really is just the
ndarray the multi-dimensional way and
operations that are performed around it
so in the umpire you can create an array
that looks like this and you can do
things like broadcast multiple
multiplications across the entire array
and you can do things like fancy
indexing and you do things you can look
at the num pyar rain when you actually
look very closely at this ndarray you
immediately see something that is very
unpaid onic yesterday steve Gower gave a
fantastic talk about what's new in
Python 3.5 and one of the things that
was added to Python 3.5 was the math
module now has a function called is
closed that allows you to determine if
two numbers are close enough by some
relative or some absolute metric some
threshold and I asked Steve well can you
see if two numbers are adjacent and a
language like Julia it's very easy to
see if two numbers or adjacent that is
if they're integer representations are
right next to each other that is if they
differ by most 10 but this is not
something that you do in Python this is
something that's foreign to Python
because Python doesn't deal with
floating point numbers in terms of
machine types in fact Python tries as
hard as it can to get away from a notion
of floating point numbers as machine
type so we don't care if it's a float 32
or float64 it's just some floating point
number and an indication of this is for
example in Python 3 this the behavior of
truncating division as a default when
you divide two integers has been
eliminated it's thought that if you do
3/2 it doesn't make sense to give one it
doesn't make sense to give a non
floating point result to truncate
the point 5 at the end of that because
we're trying to build a number of
numeric system for humans not one that
requires knowledge of the machine but
none pi immediately brings us back to
your attention because the d-type on a
numpy and dra is always a machine time
and it's always defined in terms of the
machine type and it's something that are
already at the most basic sense of just
creating an umpire in the air with a
couple of numbers in it does not
integrate into normal Python because you
can take a numpy and dra and stick
really big instant it and add one to it
and immediately the behavior is
completely different and if you had a
list and you added one to each element
because there'll be machine types
they'll overflow they'll wrap around
you'll have all the behaviors they'd
expect from for example limited 64-bit
floating point or two's complement
integers that you don't see an actual
idiomatic Python well let's let's think
a little bit higher what numpy is and
wine umpire works in this way and why
numpy is useful or how it's actually
integrating to code and and when I think
about numpy I think of it as being a
very useful tool for providing a
restricted constrained computation
environment what you can think is that
pure python has as minimal connection to
things like machine types as they can
get away with because they don't want
programmers to have to think about that
stuff they want to programmers have to
think at a much higher level in terms of
the symbols are manipulating in terms of
more humane structures like humane
number systems and they don't want you
to have to think about this is a float
32 vs of float64 this is an in 32 vs in
64 this is an unsigned in person versus
assignment they don't want you to have
to worry about those characteristics
that are more for the benefit of machine
than for the human however one of the
reasons that we write code for the
benefit of machine is that this is for
implicitly the event of the human in
terms of performance namely nobody
really wants to write Fortran and we
still do right Fortran we still do
demean ourselves by writing too but in
this fashion because we want the
performance that
subjugating ourselves to the Machine
gives us a numpy provides this to us in
Python by by giving this constrained
computation environment that is you have
a domain in which all the computations
are performed the machine types the
concert in' certain assumptions can be
made in that computation environment
there are barriers between that
computation environment and the rest of
your code it's almost like an embedded
dsl in Python and that's how we get some
performance back out numpy forces us to
make certain assumptions about the types
and the operations that is in pure
python if you add two things together
all that's going to happen is you call
Pine number multiply and what actual
code runs after that pie number multiply
is completely and totally arbitrary an
example of that is in Python 3 path lib
if you add a slash to path lip it means
path concatenation and so you have an
addition operator that's no longer
commutative you have all of these
algebraic properties are being broken
just because the plus can mean whatever
you want it to me whereas a numpy you
know the types that you're performing on
and you know exactly what those
operations are and you know them to the
level of what the machine will know for
example if you have an ndr a full of
floats and you add it's going to call
your equivalent for whatever machine you
have that your is going to call the
assembly instruction at some point that
corresponds to the addition of floating
point numbers there are other
constraints that are enforced upon you
when you deal with a numpy India right
and one of the big ones is the
independence of identities if you have a
list of Python elements there are no
constraints over what computations can
be hidden behind a numeric operation so
if you were if you had a list of Python
objects and you were to add two of them
there's no reason why that addition
couldn't subtly through some global
namespace affect some of the other
elements in the list because these are
pure these are rich Python objects and
there's any computation can be can be
put behind your underscore at whereas a
numpy because you're restricting
yourself to these very very constrained
numeric operations you can do something
like parallel broadcast and operation to
an array because you know there's an
independence of those entities
so let me show you kind of a brief
example of this numpy approach and this
numpy approach ends up being very much a
building blocks approach so one example
is if you wanted to take a
volume-weighted average price in finance
you'd construct it by taking this
building block of an average and a
building block of these dumped ind
arrays and you call the average function
with a keyword argument called weights
and you'll be there if you wanted to do
something like an exponential moving
average you do the exact same thing with
numpy you take this building block that
represents a convolution you pass it the
kernel and you build a colonel with a
building block that represents an
exponential series and you'd divide it
by the song you do the convolution you
have an exponential moving average and
this is off of what the numpy approach
looks like you have these very large
building blocks that you're cooking
together but at some point you have a
domain transformation now before we get
into where numpy poorly integrates into
the vernacular of Python let's discuss
two other approaches to other modeling
approach to other conceptualizations of
how code can be structured one of them
is your so called integrated environment
your graph computing environment so at
some point all of your going to see some
some piece of code where instead of
constraining the computations to one
area of the code where you get all of
your numbers up front there's a bunch of
matrix operations and at the end of the
matrix operations all of those results
leak out into the rest of the system
that does some data feeds or mechanics
or actually feeds it to whatever control
system is being manipulated you have all
of these smear together and some
integration computer in some integrator
environment and one view of these are
your graph computing environments so
you'll see some code that looks like
this and it may have a decorator that
tags some method on some object as being
a node in a graph computation so in this
case is a financial example you have a
portfolio and the value of the portfolio
is the sum of the individual values of
the positions of the portfolio and for
the position its value is its size times
its price and if that happens to be a
bond its price happens to be it's 30
price and it's dirty price happens to be
it's clean price plus the accrual if
it's amortized bond it might have some
additional behavior on top of that it's
a CD s it's the present value of the
cash flows and so on
and this will build a graph and you can
do some neat things with that graph like
you can do perturbative risk where you
change some of the nodes and you do the
minimal set of computations necessary in
order to revalue the entire portfolio
but what what distinguishes this
approach from numpy approach is that you
have these computations these valuation
computations and they are smeared in
your code base and intermingled with
things which are not related to
computations at all because every time
you see a computing environment like
this with a price and a dirty price
these two computation fields on them
you're almost inevitably going to see
some additional fields like registration
type or indicative information about the
bond a registration type indicative
information have absolutely no relation
to the pricing of this or lease no
direct relation or not direct input into
the pricing model what they are are
regulatory or legal entities that are
added on to these rich objects I had a
conversation a very nice conversation
last week where programmer who is trying
to build a game using pi game was asking
about numpy and one interesting thing
about the PI game approach or all of
these game programming libraries is that
they always construct the code in the
same fashion they have individual game
objects sprites that correlate to Python
objects they have computations provided
on top of these objects the individual
objects can do things or quotations or
transformations but you have individual
python objects corresponding to
individual semantic objects in the game
so you'll have an object for you know
weapon you'll have an object for a
monster and you'll have the conceptual
objects that you have in the model of
what you're trying to express I have a
one-to-one correspondence with the
actual Python objects you're dealing
with you're not aggregating them all up
in a numpy ndarray and doing matrix
transformations on them and this allows
you to do a lot of neat things like you
know it might be nice if you have a
monster you could do monster left hand
weapon damage and have these nice long
attribute lockup chains but it
eliminates your ability to do a lot of
very efficient aggregate computations
and what ends up happening in many cases
is you dispatch these aggregate
computations to some other library like
in this particular case PI chipmunk and
some physics library and what that does
is you
register each of these individual
objects and then behind the scenes these
get aggregated into some larger more
efficient representation in order to do
agric computations but nobody writes
games with this numpy approach nobody
writes games where the game objects
themselves where the billiards on a
billiards table are just rose and a
matrix even though it might be a very
efficient way to perform agric
computations across every entity they
always write it as each individual
billiard ball as an individual Python
object and it's a very different way of
structuring that code so let me show you
why numpy doesn't really integrate into
the way that we're written we write
Python it conflicts with idiomatic
Python usage even in the most basic
cases so if we go into our canonical
resource for what's considered idiomatic
Python pep eight we see this we see we
see this exhortation that if we want to
determine if a sequence has any entities
we say if not sequence or if sequence as
opposed to if length sequence or if not
sequence and we're told this is bad
style and this is good style and this is
works perfectly fine with Python if you
have a list of entities and you do if
that list it'll tell you if it's empty
or not and the moment you try this or
the moment you write some function that
takes this and you accidentally pass a
numpy ndarray it you get this or what
it's a Huffington would be a totally
inscrutable error message about the
truth value of an array being ambiguous
please use any or all and you think if
you want to write a function that
performs some basic operation on all the
elements of some iterable and you were
to say well python allows me to talk
about it herbals in a higher sense it
allows me to talk about intervals not in
the concrete sense of lists and tuples
but in the abstract sense of anything
being iterated over and a numpy ndra can
be iterated over therefore it's also an
iterable so I should be able to write a
function that takes both numpy ND arrays
and lists then the only way to write
this so it will work with both is to
write it in what is explicitly a non
idiomatic Python style it's a very small
and very trivial example but you can see
immediately the use of the numpy ndarray
does not integrate with the use of these
pure
Python structures you also see in many
cases numpy predates much of what we
consider to be contemporary Python I
feel like an archaeologist here but or a
sociologist ever but it predates much of
what we consider to be idiomatic
contemporary Python like generators so
here's an example of a generator and
it's just a simple generator that
construct the Fibonacci sequence and if
you try and stick in a numpy in the
array you end up with this it ends up
creating an umpire in da with one
element that happens to be a generator
and why it does that you can make an
argument for why that's a reasonable
thing to do or an unreasonable thing to
do and I won't argue that it's
reasonable or unreasonable but i will
say that it's often a surprising result
and it's an indication of where somebody
a well-meaning individual might apply
what they consider to be idiomatic
contemporary python users creating
generators instead of instead of
materializing or instead of performing
your computations on materialized lists
they would create a generator to porm
that computation and they'll try to put
that into a numpy ndarray and they'll
realize they need to stick a list
materializer right in between there to
actually make a work and and it's a
little bit of friction that's added into
the process as a consequence of this
this break this this impedance mismatch
between these two domains and if you
actually look at it you can see if you
actually want to put this generator now
bear in mind this Jenner is an infinite
sequence but say we sliced it and we got
out some values or save its generator
that produced a finite sequence if we
wanted to stick that into an amp int
array the structure of the code would be
the array on the outside then a list
value constructor then the generator and
that list value constructors a shim
right it's a shim that's matching up the
impedance on both sides of these domains
it's a domain transformation it's
transforming from the Python domain into
this num pioneer domain you can see that
numpy style does not integrate well with
rich Python objects with a style that we
enjoy using in language in in tools like
Network X so network X as we all know is
the library for representing networks
and we can do some neat things with
Network X we can add weights to the
edges let me do nice things with the
with the weighted edges like
use these weights or these arbitrary
attributes in order to implement all
sorts of pathfinding algorithms but
numpy does not allow us to easily do
that in fact at the very at the most
basic numpy does not allow us to perform
customized sorts so in Python we have
this sorted builtin and it allows us to
sort a list of numbers and if we want to
sort these numbers by their apps by
their magnitude by their absolute value
we just pass a key function and the key
function would be mapped to every
element of that iterable and it would
sort it by that so you can see these
numbers are sorted not by their but by
their absolute value not by their actual
value how do we do this a numpy well we
don't have a key function that we can
provide we have no way to take that
additional behavior and inject that into
numpy so we'll do is what back in the
day we used to call a decorate sort on
decorate or a schwartz ian transform
will take the numpy in the array and
instead of sorting it will first
transform it into another domain by
doing an absolute value broadcast
computation then we'll perform the
sorting in that domain will do the arc
sort and then we'll pull the elements
back into will actually pull the
elements will or rather will pull the
elements back into the unsorted domain
so you can see we have this short c and
transform here we have to decorate the
initial values sort them on that
decorative values and then undecorated
them and we have this domain
transformation necessary because there's
this impedance mismatch between the
computations that are occurring in the
Python domain and the numpy domain and
you can see this is kind of split out
you can see the the domain
transformation here the sorting within
domain and the transformation there
there are also a lot of things that we
can do very conveniently in numpy but
there's limits to these conveniences so
we can easily represent
multi-dimensional arrays in the pipe and
we can do some nice things with those
multi-dimensional arrays like we get the
00 tellement using this older syntax we
can get the 02 02 LMK using a comet
syntax is over a matrix we can actually
even get all the elements with a
specific row or specific column we do
nice slicing some of this data but the
moment we tried to integrate pure python
oxygen to it like a dictionary the
semantics fall apart
if we have an umpire in the array where
the elements of that I'm pie interior
dictionaries how do we actually get into
that dictionary there's no mechanism to
do it if we were to do 01 we might get
the 01 value just like just like it
works for the two-dimensional array but
if we were to do 00 it doesn't make any
sense right this particular operation
this particular indexing operation only
makes sense within the construct of
numpy you can't say get the zeroth
element and then that second at second
dimension is actually some custom
structure that implements some custom
get item and that's what gets passed
that there's no mechanism for making
performing at integration so the moment
that you try to put pure python objects
into an amp int array you suddenly faced
this barrier where any communication
with that pure python object is much
less convenient than if it were just
your machine type and it was just an
integer or a float one example of this
and one example of the very bad idea for
integrating pure Python object and um
pie is something that i came across
fairly recently and in order to
demonstrate it well it started with an
overall dissatisfaction with the way
that people talk about profiling in
Python I don't like when people talk
about performance profiling efficiency
because I think most benchmarks are full
of hooey I think that most benchmarks
are I went to I went to a conference
that was full of statisticians and there
were benchmarks on every slide threw out
that conference about this being fast or
that being faster and there were
statisticians and there was not a single
mention of whether these numbers were
the mean or the median what the variance
was with that what the bars were what
the model was it's nonsense the numbers
were just complete nonsense of course if
you were to show something to be 40
times faster that maybe has some
significance but for a two percent
distant difference in speed you need a
statistical model to really say is that
significant or not anyway when it comes
to memory profiling people always ask
well how much memory does my Python
program use i'm going to write some
complex little built-in tools get size
up from the cyst module and iterates
through things doesn't double counting
as a set here or set there and it's
usually absolute nonsense because
actually analyzing how much memory of
python process uses its much
order than that if you look inside C
Python you'll see that there are many
cases where the garbage collector is not
used where instead for very commonly
allocated objects like methods there's
free lists and those free lists only
grow so the actual total amount of
memory that your program is using at any
one time may not really be as meaningful
as you think and it may not shrink with
time it may be monotonically
non-decreasing so what I thought was
let's try and get a more concrete metric
and that concrete metric is does my
application or does my program fail or
not so I wrote this very very simple
really rinky-dink bash script and what
it does is it run some arbitrary command
line with increasing you limits of
virtual memory until it stops failing
and with this I can tell I can give it a
Python script and I can say what's the
minimum amount of virtual memory that
you need in order to run to completion
and then i can try something else that I
can see if that minimum is higher or
lower and I could see how does this
affect memory pressure and there's a lot
of small test you can do well this came
into use very recently when I was
investigating a limitation of the
integration of pure python objects into
dump I which is 01 interesting result
the single command line python see from
numpy importa rey requires 84 megabytes
of virtual memory in order to run
without falling over now there's still
quite a bit of stuff that you could do
with that that doesn't mean that you
need to allocate additional memory in
order to do any other computation but
this is the high-water mark and anything
lower than that on this system with this
installation is not nothing but you can
see the approach that's being taken here
we have some program we could see is it
falling over or not and there's a much
more concrete analysis even though it's
a very rough analysis well what I did
was I took a simple script and in that
simple script I took two numpy India
race and I create a circular reference
between the two of them and I stuck a
Python object into one of them and then
I stuck that into a loop and I wanted to
see what happened with garbage
collection and what happened with
garbage collection is numpy India race
when they're circular references
will not clean up any Python object sir
there's a memory leak and so when I ran
this it fell over after I found the
minimum out of memory to run this loop
once then I tried to run this loop as
many times as possible garbage
collecting after every iteration of the
loop and it fell down immediately after
the first loop and this is I think a
very clear indication of a very clear
and very tangible indication of an issue
with memory allocation and if we were to
perform the exact same thing with sorry
if we just perform the exact this with
the numpy and dra UT memory error and if
we were to perform it with pure python
list it runs forever because the Python
list when you have circular references
and they get garbage collected
everything is cleaned up because pure
python lists implement part of the
Python object model called TP traverse
which is so the dell is not called when
you garbage collect something TP
traverse is called and TP reverse goes
through and clears all of the references
that the two elements on either side of
the circular reference are holding onto
numpy and the arrays do not call that or
they not even implement it and so it's a
consequence there's a memory leak and
you can see very immediately a very poor
integration very poor interaction
between the pure python style where
you'd expect to be able to put pure
python objects anywhere and an umpire
side so that is integration with the
vernacular the numpy approach plus a
little bit of pre talk ranting I hope
you enjoyed it I really I really enjoyed
this event so far today and I'm really
glad that all of you were able to make
it to my talk thank you so much
now questions or comments please so a
generator is a structure in Python that
was introduced I'd say five over five
years ago and the idea is sometimes you
have a desire to maybe model of
computation as a stream where you have
some data coming in and some data coming
out where the results are being
generated not you don't do you don't do
the entire computation at once you do
the computation on demand so for example
if you can think in the canonical
example there I wanted to represent an
infinite sequence but clearly I have no
I can't hold that in from the secrets of
memory but I can have the infinite
sequence modeled and a couple of lines
of code and I can pull numbers out of it
on demand and that's typically where
generator is used there's also a lot of
usages or repurposing of this for async
problem that a [ __ ] needs to be fixed
like a make a new word in on pilots
networks how well does anyone here think
pandas really integrates into pure
python it doesn't right it's rare it's
very clear it's really right nice and
really convenient using an ipod on
notebook but it's actually very clunky
to use an actual application and almost
certainly at some point there will be
different approaches that are taken I
can't say that numpy is something that
we should throw away it's a very useful
tool peter wang had a very nice comment
when he sat in on this talk and Dallas
where he suggested that numba was
Continuum's approach for rewriting a lot
of what they were getting done using
numpy in a much more pythonic fashion
so I'm on a different perspective with a
gentle eyes operation okay like I tend
to want to be very explicit or an umpire
raise hope I'm doing bitwise offs
between several raise okay so that any
all stuff okay it makes sense too
because I'm going to treat them like I'm
going to have your now treating you're
not treating the dump I ndarray as I
think it's actually opaque object right
like iphone is betraying its explicit is
better than implicit there are arguments
that can be made but one of the
assumptions in how we use pure python
structures is we assume some
transparency we assume needs to be first
class so we don't necessarily consider
them to be a barrier between the object
in the collection around the object so
in the case of the if statement you can
see there's not really a barrier there
with an umpire in the array the struck
the way that it's constructed creates
this barrier between that you have to
end up dealing with it as though it's
just a mom opaque object where it's not
where you don't have syntax reaching
into that object to performing
operations the same way they do for the
list whether that's idiomatic or nada
that's good idea or not I don't know
that I can comment on anyway thank you
so much
you